[Music]
the makers the dreamers the scientists
the artists the researchers the
engineers the challengers the game
changers with fearless
today we work
[Music]
the myth debunkers secures of cyberspace
and drivers of the driverless the
climate leaders the energy shapers and
front liners of artificial intelligence
today we work the founders of new field
the bosses of brain science the smarts
behind smart cities the industry
disruptors pioneers of planetary
robotics and architects of what's next
today we live it breathe it love it
write it rewrite a nail it we have
attacked New Groove start up start over
tinker imagine and dare today we work